هكذا تغير المشهد فجاه في باريس ما كان
احد يتوقع ان هذا الحي التجاريه وسط
العاصمه سيستبغوا في لون الدم
ظهور وصدمه وتعاطف مع الضحايا
واسئله كثيره حول الفاعل واسباب الفعل
لم تتوضح كل الاجابات لكن ما تبين منها
يدفع في اتجاه بعينه العنصريه
ولديه سابقتان الاولى تتعلق باشخاص كانوا
في الخيام فهجمهم وبشان الطابع العنصري
للاحداث طبعا سيكون ذلك جزءا من التحقيق
في وسط الجليه الكرديه التي استهدفها
الهجوم بلغ لاحتقان اشده
وتحول الى مواجهه مع الشرطه
المحتجون بالحجاره
وسط المشهد غابت تفاصيل جريمه اذكت نار
المخاوف من انك رهيه الاجانب قد تكون وصلت
الى حد القتل
السلطات الفرنسيه عن الطبع العنصري
المحتمل لهذه الجريمه لم يصفها احد من
المسؤولين بانها جريمه ارهابيه
اترى ذلك غضبا في صفوف قيادات الجمعيات
الكرديه في فرنسا الذين فتحوا الجريمه على
كل الاحتمالات ممكنه بما فيها السياسيه
مقبولا اليوم فيه اطار هذه القضيه لا يتم
اعتماد صيغه الارهابيه من بين الضحايا
مسؤوله في حركه النساء الكرديه في فرنسا
لذلك هناك طبيعه سياسيه وارهابيه
[موسيقى]
فقد اعاد هذا الحادث ان النقاشه بشان
التطرف اليمني الى الواجهه
اما اقصد اليمين فقد وجد نفسه في موقف حرج
كان صمته مدويا هذه المره ومن تحدث منه
اكتفى بالعام من القول
فمواصفات المتهم هذه المره لا تنطبق عما
يمكن ان يخدم اطروحته
كله تفاصيل الجريمه لكنه مؤشراتها تقول
انها ذات طبيعه عنصريه وهذا يعني بالنسبه
لكثيرين ان التطرف اليمنيه قد خطا خطوه
اخرى من التحريض على الاجانب الى اطلاق
الرصاص عليه